again the sleet start okay well I didn't
didn't lose much time this is so this is
okay it's no kids
yeah I played this guy earlier oh yeah
on the road a couple of days ago still
have a terrible score at the last game I
won pretty convincingly I remember that
oh that was so quick I need to wait you
as a setup but okay
I like G to Bishop g2 92 against this
but Sookie and I can also do it like
they're really okay hmm interesting
yeah well does this dis make some sense
against the fianchetto but okay this is
no Bank oh yeah he's got Bishop on e7
and a close center so it's not a regular
type of bank or gambit Queen a5 maybe
this kind of thing yeah we'll see
Bishop f1 king f-14 king D - I really
cannot believe that this should be
enough compensation okay so I actually
get canceled that's that's useful okay
let's see I can trade the bishop which
is not very useful in this kind of
position so I'm threatening ninety-two
for the CAPTCHA here
if he goes night d3 what is the best
reply is b3 is b3 okay I mean okay it
certainly is but at least I think but I
wonder if I have something better
okay that's gonna be three Knight takes
e4 I mean Bishop a5 I have Knight see
form let's see
the issue is isn't a self pin this is a
almost a self pin so not so easy
yeah certainly rupiah maybe cannot take
C 3 because the 8 hangs
I want to keep this this pin going
look III would actually threaten rook
takes a five isn't this interesting
Queenie cannot move this looks
interesting
yeah I've got 95 that was my idea
night see for now do I overlooked
something
oh it's let's just look at this for a
moment
quint trading the Queen first it's not
helping no but this should really win
win this win this thing might be seven
yeah but this this really looks very
groveling so he's giving away the Queen
can i play 96 or something like that no
does not look like it but what is a good
way I want to enter with the Queen here
quickly
it's rook is tied to d6 how do I enter
here quickly in queen g4 probably for
Queen c8
trying to win this d6 pawn if I win that
is six-pointed it all falls apart
don't really see anything anything
decent now okay then I can go there with
a shaky check then take on d6 I cannot
take 26
okay so Knight a5 then for knight c6 can
hardly believe that this shouldn't win
like immediately
but maybe okay it hanging on then I get
dese exam
check I'm so taking taking this check
check
he can just take it that was stupid
but I still get got the a pawn of course
check-check
check
hmm
they let the clock run down oh you don't
know I mean I understand you I often am
frustrated when I lose but that seemed
pretty straightforward really but like I
mean not like he spoiled some brilliant
position or so well no he lets the clock
run down yeah I don't know
black resigned him okay well I don't
think I made a slide and made a move on
a glitch not that this is bad it's
normal move but what I wanted to do this
is what I normally play against this
opening but you like it's a very
flexible setup until he got this b5 all
of a sudden huh interesting interesting
I mean normally any kind of Benoni sorry
Banco type of idea and then the cheque
Benoni is really not working at all but
maybe here with this kind of weird
situation that I cannot cancel it it
could be valid this takes lots of time
at least this is I expected here and now
he went c4 which I don't know I mean I
thought that relatively quickly I'm here
it should be it should be nice for me
back when tier b3 I mean computer OS
gives white some advantage like have a
pawn but I thought it it was getting
serious here yeah this rook a to me
rookie a3 immediately was even stronger
but here it was very serious and white
now wins after Luke a3 this Knight c4
and end winning Knight be seven or ever
was dream was a bit tougher
it's not totally clear to me how I win
the computer gives night to d1 I mean
the positive thing is that he barely he
is barely able to move anything so I
have a bit of time to improve not quite
sure where this is heading and maybe
Here I am
mmm yeah it's ending - in this general
direction yeah okay white is white has
set up this pin it's it's very
uncomfortable and she gave gave the
cables and the Queen's edge which really
am really was losing as well okay well
thanks for watching